amen please be seated once a month I
tell you that this is a sermon that gave
me some trouble so be ready
anything could happen today if you look
in your bulletin you'll notice two
things you'll notice that there's a
brochure about our deacons who are gonna
be commissioned today so I urge you to
take a look you'll see them seated all
around you and you'll see a yellow form
and if you haven't filled one out yet I
would like to ask you to do so if you're
here for the third week it's too late
you're stuck you're hooked you're here
go ahead and fill out the form and give
us your email so it can be in touch we
want you to be a part of our community
clearly you found something here that
fits for a part of you and we would
really like to be in touch with you so
go ahead and fill out the yellow form
just leave it in your Pew and we'll pick
it up after the service but if you're if
you'd like to be a part of this this is
a great week we're starting both of our
studies this week we'll have a Bible
study on Monday and another study on
Tuesday we've got lots of activities
going on so this is the week to take
that extra step and go ahead and commit
it's also been a tough week for a lot of
people in our community because of the
disappearance of a Neely and it's
affected many people in many different
ways it's brought up a lot of fears for
people it's brought up a lot of worry
and concern for her and for all our
safety and so I just wanted to take a
moment and ask you to relax put your
bulletins down close your eyes and let's
have a moment of silence for Annie and
for her family who have arrived here in
New Haven for her fiance on this what
would have been their wedding day let's
lift them up in our prayers
God we ask your presence with the family
and the fiance of a Neely and we ask you
to return her safely to us but whatever
happens give us the grace to respond
with your Holy Spirit come in today I
have one fairly simple question for my
sermon and the question is as Jesus asks
us at the beginning of the passage from
mark who is Jesus and if we have an
answer to that question if we know who
Jesus is does that make any difference
for the question Who am I does who Jesus
is have anything to do with who I am in
our gospel passage were at the midpoint
of the Gospel of Mark the turning point
those of you who weren't here all summer
we read through all the beginning all
the wonders and miracles all the great
things Jesus did and we reached this
turning point in chapter 8 where Jesus
asked his disciples who do people say
that I am and the disciples truthfully
give their answers and they say people
some people say you're John the Baptist
come back or Elijah come back and that's
how they explain who you are but then he
asks but who do you say that I am and I
think Liz gave that just the right lilt
a little sarcasm there Oh what about you
and Peter answers you are the Messiah
but if the story ended at that point
Peter would have been fine Peter would
have come out looking like a great
disciple but the story continues and
Jesus begins teaching the disciples that
the Son of Man the human one come to
earth must suffer greatly be rejected by
the authorities and killed and Peter
pulls him aside and rebukes him and
Jesus steps back and says to Peter get
thee behind me Satan for you were
dwelling on human things not divine
things and Jesus continues and calls not
only his disciples but the whole crowd
in and says to them if any of you want
to be my followers
you must deny yourself and take up your
cross and follow me for those who want
to save their life will lose it and
those who want to lose their life for my
sake and for the sake of the gospel will
save it Oh tough message for the third
or fourth week of the semester I would
have preferred a lighter gospel but I
think within this gospel it's not
darkness it's not death but I think it's
freedom and hope but we have to look
hard does Jesus does who Jesus is make a
difference for Who I am
according to this passage if Jesus is a
miracle worker a teacher a kind and
moral man a lover of the poor and the
outcast if he is any and all of these
things and I worship Him and follow him
doesn't really change who I am
that fits with my perception of myself I
too can be a teacher I too can be a
moral person or a servant without
changing a lot about what I think about
my life or the world I'm still a normal
person but if Jesus says what he says
today and he tells me we're all going to
the cross all of us let's go he's headed
to the cross just like a common criminal
if he's headed towards suffering and
death and I still worship Him and follow
him it does change Who I am because I
can't be a normal good person if I'm
willingly following him to his death I
become a crazy person so welcome
crazy people
no sane person wants to suffer and die
if Jesus is a failure and a criminal and
so am I and so who he is becomes a very
important part of who we are and worse
yet he says if I want to follow him I
have to deny myself and take up my own
cross and follow him deny myself follow
him to the cross
doesn't sound like the path to happiness
and fulfillment doesn't it's funny how
we skip this part a lot of the time when
we're telling people about Jesus it's
all about fulfilment wholeness joy who
would be crazy enough to worship this
man Saint Peter wasn't responding
unreasonably when Jesus rebuked him I
would have done the same and I daresay
you would have done the same if I were
to get up here and say okay it's all
been great so far but I'm gonna suffer
and die and you should too I think I'd
be out of a job
I think Calista would call Lyn Delorme
er and report me I would have done the
same thing Peter did I would have said
of course you're not going to suffer and
die Jesus you're too nice people like
you and we've got so much invested in
you if you suffer and die then
everything we've given to you is worth
nothing Jesus is saying if you can't
stand where my path is headed then
you're following me for the wrong
reasons because the path I'm
trailblazing and that you're following
leads to losing your life and to
understand Jesus I think we need to ask
that question the second question which
life am i losing and which life am i
saving
he says we're gonna lose one and we're
gonna gain one which one is which which
part of our life really fits they're my
guests from everything Jesus says is
that I'm supposed to lose the life
that's based on what other people have
told me about what I should do and who I
should be it's the very modern life we
all lead and it I think it's part of
living in such an egalitarian society
and especially amongst high achievers as
many of you are in this room a life
that's based on some weird compromise
between what I need to do to keep other
people happy and we are people pleasers
and what I need to do to keep myself
occupied and sated not just keeping
others happy but also distracting them
from my flaws keeping them pleased with
the good things I do for them and in the
same way with myself keeping my focus
away from who I really am what my real
problems are and keeping myself happy
with the stories I tell myself about Who
I am the stories I tell myself that keep
a thin fog over everything I know that
sounds odd but isn't that the life most
of us lead the life stuck somewhere on
that fairly narrow spectrum between
trying to please other people and trying
to please myself how can I find a career
that I will enjoy that will still make
my parents happy and make me lots of
money how can i balance my relationships
and my work and still have time for
myself how can I make new friends at
Yale join ten clubs and take six classes
and get straight A's in all of them how
do I do that it's that fine line between
pleasing other people and pleasing
myself Jesus is saying deny that self
and follow me and you'll find a
different self branched off Regan quotes
an old book I remember some of you will
remember from back in the 70s
by John Powell a Jesuit called why am I
afraid to tell you who I am it was sort
of a psychological pop psychology
spirituality book of the time and Powell
had a statement in there that I think is
more profound than the genre he said I'm
afraid to tell you who I am because if I
tell you who I am you may not like Who I
am and that's all I have
let's do it again I'm afraid to tell you
who I am because if I tell you who I am
you may not like Who I am and that's all
I have so rather than risk being hurt we
don't tell others who we are trying to
protect and save ourselves from pain we
lose ourselves we pretend we become
hypocrites we become non selves in our
relationship to other people this is
what the life that Jesus is asking us to
lose the functional even successful self
that exists to pervert preserve itself
and protect itself and eventually out of
fear ceases to grow and change the self
that believes I'm all that I have and
Jesus says that self needs to die so
that you can have another self my friend
Rebecca chop who is president at
Swarthmore College and was briefly here
at Yale said that someday we're going to
regret telling college students that the
goal of life is to go out and find your
passion she said it was a great thing
one at one point because it encouraged
people not to listen to their parents
talking about making lots of money or
listen to their peers that were telling
them they had to have three majors but
rather said go out and find your passion
but she said what is a passion she said
a passion is just one moment in your
life when you felt successful and
creative and useful is it worth basing
the rest of your life on that one moment
she said passion is it bad but it's
rooted it's not rooted in anything
deeper than what I like and what I'm
good at I think that the life Jesus
calls us to lose is the life defined by
our passions and he asks us to save a
life defined by his passion one of my
favorite stories about how you know
you're in the right path is a funny
story you've heard me tell about Pablo
Casals
perhaps the greatest cellist ever it was
touring the United States in 1901
traveling across the nation and he was
supposed to do 80 different engagements
but halfway through the tour he was
climbing in the mountains near San
Francisco and someone up above him
kicked back a rock as he was sort of
clambering up the side of the mountain
and this rock came down and fell on his
hand and crushed his fingers pretty
rough for a cellist he said the first
thought that came to his mind when he
looked at his crumpled hand was thank
God I'll never have to play the cello
again at least at that moment early in
his life Casals didn't embrace his life
as a cellist as a path towards happiness
or pursuing a passion his life as a
cellist sounds like something between a
mania and a compulsion and the life
Jesus wants us to find is the life we
can't seem to avoid that life we feel
strangely compelled to follow not the
life of our own fulfillment or anyone
else's fulfillment
I think this different life is not about
success it's not about pleasing others
or even pleasing your idea of who you
think you are or who I think I am it is
about as my old friend Glenn Mitchell
has written gaining the freedom to be
fully present to life which has
everything to do with accepting our
death and our suffering
and letting go of our efforts to control
life Jesus invites us to let go of our
grip on life enough to create a holy
space for the gift of God's presence
here and now
to the old life of trying to meet
everyone's expectations rising again to
only his expectations for us to love and
sacrifice for others how do you know
what's the right path my rule of thumb
that it is whatever would hurt the most
to give it up whatever would sink
deepest into your definition of who you
are in relation to yourself and other
people because that's the one where all
the trouble is built in that's the life
that's hardest to let go of like
publicus all's I think the true / the
true life of purpose often feels more
like a compulsion than a choice it may
not be something you're good at how
could that be how could God call me to
something I'm not perfect at exactly
what God calls us to if you read your
Bible it may not be something that makes
me deeply happy but it's something we
can't not do because we can feel God's
Spirit leading us towards it the great
illusion of our time as Daniel Gilbert
the Harvard psychologist wrote in his
book stumbling on happiness is that we
think we know what will make us happy
the greatest delusion of all time
and we strive for it and strive for it
and we get it and we're still not happy
but we keep going after it and we get it
again and we're still not happy that
next boyfriend that next car their next
achievement the next job that's the one
that will make me happy right at our
deacons retreat last weekend a number of
the Deacons remarked that because the
church didn't place a lot of specific
demands on them when push came to shove
and other groups were desperate for help
and studies piled up Church got set
aside somebody else would do it
they showed real courage and honesty to
admit this and we all do it even mean
not just with this church but with a
whole call of Christ I think what we
need is sacrifice defined as the
dictionary does as for going something
valued for the sake of something having
a more pressing claim the gospel has
pressing claim on us than the stories we
tell ourselves about ourselves when we
answer the question who is Jesus and we
see in him a figure of triumphant glory
or social change or personal fulfillment
we end up defining ourselves by goals
that are less than ultimate we achieve
power or change or whatever circumstance
we thought would make us happy and we
end up thinking is that all there is but
if we take up the cross he gives us a
note this is a very important point it's
not the cross we choose a cross that
someone else chooses for us if we take
up the cross he gives us our lives
become not successful or even thrilling
or even blissful but they become holy
which is more lasting than any of those
things our lives become our own way our
lives become our own in a way the lives
we would choose for ourselves could
never be and we can welcome our true
selves without fear and love others
without judgment if he's going to the
cross we go with him what we lose is
nothing to regret what we lose is just
busy work to justify ourselves to
ourselves and to others what we gain is
the simple freedom of following him